[Music]
this morning we are learning about an
alarming trend people have discovered
that strangers are tracking their every
move using apple air tags the tags are
small bluetooth devices that are
supposed to help you keep track of your
belongings like a purse or a child's
backpack you put the air tag inside and
then you track it on your phone sounds
simple maybe too simple because some
people are using these air tags to stalk
others inside edition's lisa guerrero
reports on two different women who
realized they were being tracked by
someone else
in atlanta body cam obtained by inside
edition shows cops finding an air tag in
this woman's gas tank i randomly got a
notification to my phone saying
something about how
there is an
air tag that doesn't belong to me that's
been with me even cops weren't sure what
to do next this is my first instance of
running into something like this so i
also don't even know how to go about
trying to identify unbelievably it's
generally not illegal in georgia and
several other states to put a tracker on
another person's car how shocked were
you to discover that you were being
tracked it scares me to death i mean i
really feel helpless this atlanta woman
says an air tag followed her every move
from the mall to her house how does she
know because apple created an iphone
safety feature that notifies users when
it detects an unknown device following
them my feeling is if they've done it to
me i'm probably not the only one but
where was it she couldn't find a little
air tag and she looked everywhere she
figured it had to be in her car there's
only so much you can do
yourself without getting underneath the
car
so we took her to an auto shop and had a
team of train technicians comb the
vehicle but even they couldn't find it a
device this small could really fit
anywhere absolutely i mean there are a
thousand places this could go you can do
everything in your power to protect
yourself but the fact that someone with
bad intentions can track you and there's
nothing you can do about it is really
scary and really frustrating
apple says it's committed to air tax
privacy and security air tag is designed
with a set of proactive features to
discourage unwanted tracking if users
ever feel their safety is at risk they
are encouraged to contact local law
enforcement who can work with apple to
provide available information about the
unknown air tech inside edition anchor
deborah norville joins us right now uh
good morning hey so what do you do if
you get the alert on your phone that
there is an air tag well here's the
first thing you don't do you don't go
home you don't go to your office you
don't go to a place that you regularly
would go to because then you've just
given them all the information they need
the best thing to do is go to the police
station and say first of all if they're
tracking the police station they're not
going to come in there say i'm being
tracked there's an uh indication on my
phone that there is an air tag somewhere
in my person or on my car
can you help me and as the young woman
in atlanta who has it on her car she
went to the police the police said go to
apple apple said go to the police it's
like a cat chasing her tail she still
has this thing somewhere on her car
short of taking the car apart
they don't know how to find it and so
she has to wait for the battery to go
dead and the battery lasts for a year
yes that is he still doesn't know you
know that is such good advice you said
about don't go home because i think your
instinct is well let me go home and let
me call somebody so i think that's very
important to put that out there but
deborah how is it not illegal that
somebody could put a tracking device on
you and your car and your purse and your
coat and it and and that's okay that
that is not illegal so first of all this
is how small this thing is and you oh
it's glued down um you wouldn't
necessarily even know that this has been
slipped into your coat pocket in fact
one of you has one in your chair
seriously seriously you know what i bet
you it's me because i don't usually use
a pillow and i did notice there's a
pillow here okay
yep there it is yeah look at that
but even tony
look at that i'm a detective because
that one's mine
even if we hadn't had the pillow there
we could have slipped it right there you
would have never known you could slip it
between the outside door and the car
window and maybe
magnetic there's part of it that's
magnetic and part of it isn't here's the
thing um
about why it's illegal why is it not
illegal in the state of georgia my home
state thank you very much it is not
illegal to put a tracking device on the
exterior of a car
provided you do not stalk or harass the
person who is being tracked
well rott's a rock on that what other
reason would you be putting it on to
just idly follow someone so
understandably this children is very
very afraid
um a cheating husband i gotta be the
husband girl you can do that
if you got the cheating oh did i say
that out loud i'm not gonna say that out
loud but but that actually would be
legal because that's your vehicle yeah
right so that would not be against the
law i would kind of hope that apple
would consider putting a consent
notification so if you do get a note on
your phone that says you're being
tracked by an unknown device right you
would be able to check yes or no if you
recognize it or not and if you don't
then right that's an issue well one
reason that that apple has made this is
alert is this alert out there is so that
people will know they're being tracked
and they do on your ios and the reason
we're hearing about this now is
the new update 14.5 and further will let
you know if there's a tracking device
and so people are now finding these
things out but if you find it out you
can't find it it really ruins your
potential your year as you wait for the
battery to go but at least you'll be on
guard though but what you're going to do
is you can hit a button on the alert and
it will ping the device and so it'll
make a sound that's how the girl with
the air tag in her gasps
hanging down there
what if you have an android phone okay
good question
just last month apple released an app
called track detector that allows
anybody with an android phone to do the
same thing there's a few problems with
it it uses the same bluetooth technology
to find the device you can then ping it
with the um with the the sound mechanism
but you have to go on to your phone and
actively look for the device the apple
ios version of it automatically does it
and alerts you if you've got an android
phone you have to open the app and then
and then search and the other thing
about the ios so the girl with the one
on her car that they can't find
she believes that whoever is tracking
her is turning the tracking on and off
oh wow so she's tried to ping it and
make the sound and she can't get it too
so say you do find this tag right
um can you track the person who bought
it
presumably yes and there is a serial
number associated with each one of these
um air tags the challenge is getting
apple to track that serial number i was
speaking with producer about that very
question nate and she said
i am aware of no one who's been able to
get apple to do that debra this is
valuable information exactly everybody
saved lives yeah everybody's going to be
talking about this no doubt deborah
noble thank you so much good to see you
in the studio inside edition is
distributed by cbs media ventures uh
division of viacomcbs it airs weekdays
so you can check your local listings